okay so therefore as this alternative
way of thinking is right this is not
just one function even though I can
expand it and I can see it like this
this is a function of a function do you
get that idea
like I'm squaring which is a function a
function I'm applying a function to
function okay so how can I work with
this thing well let's get one of the
functions out of the way right here's
what I'm going to do this is like sort
of a critical new step I know how to
differentiate things if it's just being
squared that's really easy okay so in
order to have this thing is just
something being squared I'm gonna
introduce the substitution I'm going to
say let's and this is why I adjust you
and B yesterday cuz they're kind of
traditional sort of my name is I'm going
to let this motion here 4x squared plus
1 I'm going to let it equal to this I'm
just gonna give it a name just gonna
give a name right so you see I'm writing
this U is a function of X that's what we
said before I'm just going to name it
you now I don't really need to say that
you know that that bracket there you
bracket X I'm sort of just implying that
just like normally when you see y equals
write you know Y is a function of X so
this is true but I could just say u
equals that now just have a look at this
for a second this function you okay
I could differentiate this cart i I can
differentiate this by itself
except it's not dy/dx is it because the
original function is not called Y the
original function is just a label it's
just called you so when I find the
derivative of this thing it's not dy/dx
it's D u does that make sense
just a label ok what is the derivative
of this function here let's just say x2
comes down at the front power reduces
the one contributes nothing okay so
that's all Val and dandy but when I
introduce this substitution right this
is not the real problem
this is the real problem okay so keeping
this in mind I can rewrite this guy Y
which is also a function of it
is this which is you sweat do you agree
with that like that's that's the
substitution I've made that's why I
picked you to be equal to 4x squared
plus 1 so it could replace that thing up
there
you could replace that thing a bit so
here's my function and he's my function
of the function right U is a function
and I'm squaring it okay now down here
I can't differentiate this as well
usually I think of dy/dx right because Y
is the name of the function and then X
is what I'm differentiating with
respects you that's the variable that
I'm looking at I should apply my rules
of bringing powers down and so on but my
variable here is not called X it's
called you so should not be due on DX it
should be dy on do you do you see that
so I'm differentiating this with respect
to a different variable you different
with respect to a different function but
this is great this is just you Square
this is the simplest it can get well not
the simplest but it's where we started
before for calculus right I just bring
the power out the front all there is to
it so now let's think about what this
means to you okay is this three video
and ax is this derivative but you can
see and this is part of the reason why
we did this right like this notation
here is meant to indicate rise over run
rise over run rise over run the
different rises and different runs okay
the rise in this case is exactly the
same run in this case right there the
same quantity do you see that so this is
more than just remember I said oh like D
on yes right you ever I said this is an
operator it operates on functions okay
it's more than just an operator but it
is actually meant to indicate a fraction
and so on that basis we can work with it
just like we work with normal fractions
what am i after I'm after that I'm after
the actual derivative you can see the
actual derivative is a fairly
straightforward combination of these two
being that these are fractions
I can say what I really want is dy/dx so
it's a simple matter of multiplying
these two derivatives here right do Y on
do u times du/dx right because these
these do use here and here in a manner
of speaking
can cancel it's a bit weird that we
cancelling of it because remember what
these things are taking a limit these
things are actually both in a way zero
okay they're not exactly zero and
they're the same not exactly zero so
therefore they can actually I'll just do
it in a different color I can cancel
these two and all I get left with is
dy/dx so now I'm just gonna put this
into place okay d why do you it's two
times you but remember U is actually
this right that's actually what you read
so this is to 4x squared plus one that's
what to you is this from this line okay
and then I'm multiplying by D yuan DX
that's 8x outside of 4x squared plus one
which if I just want to make it really
obvious I'll expand out I don't need to
but I will looks to me like 64 X cubed
plus 16x
so this was not just a trick of flagging
this fraction business here by me doing
some black magic stuff this really works
is really produces exactly what we
expected right because what we did was
we reduced a problem we didn't know how
to do there's a function of a function
we separated out the functions right
once you've got the functions on the
road you can deal with them we just
differentiated them according to the
rules we've already established by first
principles okay so therefore this guy up
here this this statement up here very
very simple statement okay it has two
names number one because what is D
with is a function of a function so this
is called the function of a function
rule that's what helps us to
differentiate okay but as you can well
imagine function of a function rule is a
bit of a bit of a mouthful so more
colloquially what it's called and this
is what I want to say from now on I'm
not going to say what term function
anymore it's called the chain rule it's
called the chain rule because what you
have here when you look at this it's
kind of like a chain of derivatives
where the studio is you they're kind of
like the common link but these two
pieces are linked together and therefore
they cancel and give you back the
original version if you want okay so
this is a chain of derivatives that's
strung together to give you the actual
derivative that you want you have to
take two of them